it gets warmer once the doors close
we'll turn the sprinklers unreal you're
listening to the dollop this is a
bi-weekly American history podcast once
a week I fruit eater mm man of the
people
Burbank wanderer Dave Anthony where were
you wandering reads a story from
American history
to my friend I want to know where you're
going Gareth Reynolds who has no idea
what the topic is going to be about but
where are you where if you want I'll
tell you why I got lost in Ikea
yesterday it's a big store
it's a biggest store biggest IKEA in the
world and it is terrifying in there it
sounds like a black mirror it is a black
mirror and they keep having things a
shortcut this way it's not shortcut you
just realize you start new lives in the
kitchen area yeah no for sure
oh look honey Sam got an A in algebra no
he didn't because he couldn't get out of
the store you can find his way out in
the morning to go shut up they'll kill
us if we don't keep the Roos going ha ha
ha
Gareth and tell you about some tour
dates that we're doing with the podcast
doesn't matter it sold out San Francisco
we've added a second show on the 2nd of
February at 9:30 p.m. Seattle we've
added a second show on February 22nd
that is also at 9:30 Portland we've
added a second show on the 23rd of
February at 9:30 p.m. Kansas City you're
sold out you don't get a second show
Indianapolis Oh
big announcement we have added a second
show on the 3rd so that will go on sale
patreon the same thing patreon on
Thursday and then to the general public
on Friday also want to announce we'll be
coming to a city called Minneapolis in
August I'm not sure the exact date I
don't have it on here but that do you
know what day it is let's say it'll let
say this would be an absolute miracle I
got it right here
so the 16th of August not
have it and it'll be at the cedar
cultural center and tickets will go on
sale Friday and then patreon presale on
Thursday I did not have that in my
filings Dave
okay so January 10th I will be at
flappers at 10:00 p.m. the 14th I will
be a bar Lubitsch doing a show called
arguments and grievances with Brian cook
and a bunch of other fantastic people
that guys awful he's a terrific
gentleman and I demand that you respect
him on the 24th I will be doing an hour
at flappers on the 27th I will be doing
setlist on the on February 14th I will
be doing a Valentine's show at flappers
for all the couples who mmm I can event
be an hour anything better than you and
couples what a great night that's great
yeah I think it's important to spend the
14th with someone that you love my mom's
here no Dave we actually have a very
special guest your mother's not here my
mother is here Pamela Reynolds why don't
you say hello mother check the levels
sibilants there we go
she had no accent the whole Mississippi
the whole time then we get in here she's
down conwoman from Mississippi accent
yeah yeah welcome I'm sorry about
everything
what about okay no this one actually be
fine for your mom you're not gonna be
uncomfortable all right look we can
handle everything about the beginning of
anal oh my god she means cleanliness
mother cleanliness someone who's plently
imagine if that was what we had and you
didn't say anything and I'm just sitting
here like go start the car mom
we should get it heated before we leave
started that was good uh
Gareth Danny say you're a guy
and you have it you having a tough week
some rough 2018
yeah someone one of your old buddies
kind of said some stuff about ya maybe a
book came out about ya
okay in which everyone said you're kind
of an idiot like a basic genuine idiot
well we know well fortunately there's
something called talk space for you
the dollop of sponsored by talk space is
an online therapy company that lets you
message a licensed therapist from
anywhere anytime all use computer
internet connection or talk space mobile
app that means you can improve your
mental health even if you've had trouble
making time for it in the past Wow Who
am I looking at can't imagine fitting
anything else into your life no I mean
no this decks pretty stacked ugh well
toxic therapies isn't easy as sending
your therapist a message get something
off your chest or whenever you need to
talk about everyday challenges at work
or at home
I just chat about life there are no
extra commutes no leaving the office and
no judgments there's definitely
judgments remember that therapy isn't
just about I'm firing Gary it's just
about venting your innermost thoughts
are digging into childhood memories it's
also about practical everyday strategies
for stress management in dealing with
maybe everyone talking about you and
also you may be going on Twitter and
saying that you're okay the same I mean
that's that's how you know you per se
that's how you know it's about living a
happier life and having a therapy simply
provides you with a designated person to
talk to who is trained to listen and to
help you make positive changes so talk
space platform has over 2000 licensed
therapists for experience in addressing
life challenges we all face to match
with a perfect therapist for a fraction
of the price of traditional therapy go
to talk space.com slash stop and use the
code doped you get $30 off your first
month and show your support for this
show
that's dub and talk space calm he's a
dollop yeah but you please rumors are
true mother I were also sponsored by a
blue apron yes this is a company makes
blue aprons yep thanks to them
okay for eight weeks what were you
expecting for me for eight weeks we
didn't we didn't do the one that would
make this eight weeks so we'll say seven
weeks yeah good we didn't do an episode
for a week sending on to 26 that's
February 26 for sure people who are
staring at me weird yeah two hundred two
hundred and twenty sixth day of the year
they apron is winning is teeming with
whole thirty to bring you delicious I
like these blue ribbon oh my god
our manual a feature to hold thirty
approved recipes each week like Mexican
spiced barramundi with avocado gorgeous
and kale and sweet potato salad
kickstart your with blue apron and whole
thirty it's a whole thirty uh a whole
thirty half would be fifteen uh you know
blue aprons grape mean Gareth use it we
like to cook together we usually do it
today over the studio but often we will
cook and then we'll do our show together
is a lot of hand-holding yeah and we do
it shirtless I'm shirtless yeah and one
guy wins the blue apron one guy gets the
blueprint that guy wears that nothing
else it's convenient there's a lot a
variety it's flexible really good
quality we we you like the vegetable
stuff I like the chicken oh there's no
need to draw a line in the sand so
you're like well I'll cook your
vegetable meal you'll cook my chicken
meal I'm not cooking your chicken
there'll be a lot of staring at each
other you like it medium rare yeah you
know I did yeah we get that medium I
like a chicken sushi nice me that's a
sound vanilla roll blue apron is
treating the DA plus'ners to $30 off the
first order if you visit blue apron comm
slash dollop so check out this week's
menu and get three dollars off with free
shipping at blue apron comm slash table
blue apron a better way to cook sure did
you have any how'd you want to read you
have any ads mom used to work for
Wrigley's do you want to do any
Wrigley's sales no I think yes Wrigley's
is gone yeah she's done with Wrigley
yeah like you always say screw Wrigley
right I do yeah that phrase
we're also sponsored by tripping comm
yep
have been since high school the average
family visits five totally different
websites before booking a vacation
rental you don't but your mom and I
might because we plan stuff yeah you can
okay you can spend less time planning a
next trip
if you use tripping calm the world's
number one site for vacation rentals
I've used it I love it
Trevor comm is trusted by millions of
travelers and it's been featured in The
New York Times it's part of the
resistance Travel and Leisure Forbes and
more if you're looking for a cabin or a
beachfront home which we like yeah we do
a lot of blue apron and our beachfront
cabin home we do or if you're looking
ahead to vacations in the spring trip
ENCOM can help you find the perfect
place to stay the Acacia mendl's off
offer flexibility perks and that means
that hotels don't like multiple bedrooms
backyards hot tubs free Wi-Fi them and
even fully stocked kitchen so you can
plan and cook your own meals it can be
really good for families and large
groups onesearch lets you filter compare
and start over 10 million available
properties on chesta sites like
TripAdvisor booking so they you can
it checks other sites sure you know I'm
talking about yeah and we've all seen I
know the search engine is sure I miss
you oh my god don't wonder if you're
getting the best deal you'll save an
average 18 percent per night by booking
a vacation with tripping dot-com so if
you want to save money time while
booking the perfect vacation rental for
your next trip head to trippin comm
slash doll today that's trippin dot-com
slash dollop trippin calm such tov that
I say that yeah eight times
mother what was it maybe one more just
to be safe I really thought we had this
all worked out
ya know little apart yeah well she
doesn't get the cut of ads anymore I
told you you had yeah that was your
chance to really make some money yeah
today yeah and mother what mother's a
mother wants me to she's not gonna she
wants me to let her know when to jump in
oh she's yeah
whatever do you know he wanted to be
spike Oh what about Nigel VGP yeah
she'll cover me the we GP because it's
Gareth Patrick and I hated it
I'd be like stop calling me the we GP so
this episode hopefully will be uh what
you lost interest real fast than that
huh yeah I don't care about your good
lord you asked prick I asked but then
what your what your mom was saying was
fine I was telling in and then you
started talking and I drifted off that
started thinking about how an errand
looks good over there is Queen shirt now
is that the bandar-e just like Queens no
yeah no it's it's Elizabeth
Elizabeth the first man my queen
this episode will hopefully be up on
YouTube we start doing that once in a
while it'll be on the ATC channel right
that's the idea so we'll be upon when do
you think you'll put it up is it take
long it'll be no editing tomorrow no
it's a good Monday night for us yeah
okay there we go if you want to see
pictures or what garrus garrus mommy
looks like also congratulations to your
Packers I have to say that my friend
yeah he's been a straight about her team
through the whole play out there out of
the playoffs [ __ ] and you know that's
not what I've been seeing
19:22 really weak your bar Lord Janos
Burgess was born in here's one ready for
this one sure
Yas barony an agricultural town in
central hungry what just happened I
should have done that to myself yeah
what's his name
Janos Burgess Janos Burgess and he's
born in the middle of Hungary yep okay
he was an only child
okay his dad liked booze and
hated Janos oh well Dave a little Yanis
and Oliver so he was said to live with
his grandparents when he was three okay
threes already worn I was welcome to
like go Yanis when he was 12 they sent
him back the grandparents you don't have
what's your Hungarian accent very
similar to some of the other accents
from Europe huh tired of Yanis he is a
bad kid no young yeah we wait a while
but he's not good it's amazing how
terrible child how I feel like I'm in
hungry right now yes yes why wait eat
Snickers when he was 15 he ran away to
Budapest
sure Wow David the shush and the baller
now Budapest
he was taken in by a butcher in his
family oh boy that happens okay a lot if
you're on the streets in Eastern Europe
often a butcher will take you and sure
right yeah he was a pilot in the Royal
Hungarian Air Force okay
Yanis claims after the war he worked for
US military intelligence although there
was no record that seems to be the good
cover job for the lunatic a lot of them
yeah they're just like I'm also in the
FBI just so you know you know I
shouldn't be telling anyone this but I'm
actually yes yeah yeah well yeah we
can't you could come buddy yeah what are
you gonna do yeah I mean I shouldn't be
talking about it but you seem cool I
actually work at the Pentagon so don't
tell anyone pinkie swear this they don't
pinky swear absolutely stronger than the
oath of office I've always said they
slice an eyeball yeah only exchange
fluids yep yeah clearly a man in the CIA
I work he was arrested by the Soviets
and charged with espionage his trial
lasted seven minutes seven minutes yeah
okay cool so they really Craig him
through there in the Eastern Bloc
countries he was sent to 25 years hard
labor in Siberia Jesus after seven
minutes and minutes
that's quite I imagine there was like a
hello how are you
was it the People's Court no oh that
yeah edit it down yeah but still not a
lot it's not like there's a lot of time
but they do like nine a day they like
uh-huh
that's why Judge Judy is so great judge
Judy's the most high Spade person on
television and deserves every penny of
it he was there for eight years in a
gulag and then released and they you
honest went back to Hungary he got the
nickname Big John okay
cuz he honest meets John yeah you knew
that right mom oh yes yeah we both knew
that mother and I share a love of
history in 1855 he met 27 year-old
Elizabeth Newell who was waiting for her
husband in a restaurant and he honest
asked her to dance and since she was
getting a divorce from her husband and
marrying Janos based on the dance it
must been a good dance so these are
different times no that still happens
what in clubs and bars I met my wife
oh my god there was a revolution in
Hungary when that was true the next year
okay you wish there was a revolution in
Hungary no I wish that you had met your
wife dancing I met her dancing yeah you
danced there's no way I can only imagine
day but people are dancing no it's you
want to dance Dave [ __ ] them [ __ ] this
exactly what happens yep so there's a
revolution in Hungary they overthrew the
communist government that doesn't go
well the Soviets were all in with tanks
okay kill everybody and then that's the
end of that night Yanis is on the wrong
side so he had to get out of Hungary now
okay wait so he's trapped well he would
he would help overthrow the government
and rights of its role and he's like I
guess I got to go okay all right so he's
granted political asylum in the United
States of America okay
it's our country yeah that's what do you
always say my best country in the world
[Laughter]
he and Elizabeth arrived in 1957 okay
they went to California and worked on a
farm okay
it's an immigrant thing we make I
already work on a farm yeah no that's
what you and Dad had to do we did
after John got a job welding and pipe
pinning they had two kids Johnny and J
for some reason some reason Jimmy has a
different last name I couldn't why do
you keep for all they're super close
well he's it's jits Johnny Burgess
senior and junior and then the other kid
is Jimmy and has a different last name I
have no idea why he has a different last
name I couldn't everywhere I looked I
couldn't figure it out well Dave this
might be the time when kids got to pick
their last name oh my god wouldn't that
be married that face that's why my kid's
name is Finnegan
but poop I'm Finn but poop I'll be doing
your taxes that is currently 50% of
wonderful man born in 1920 Oh
maybe his mom a little too real no
relative Oh Big John started a
landscaping business he hated unions and
enjoyed fighting he was a scary dude
other men were afraid of him okay so it
does sound like a relative of ours now
he had a cruel sense of humor and was a
bit reckless okay he became pretty
familiar with dynamite as you used it to
blast wells and trenches pretty familiar
with dynamite is the fun way of putting
it
what's wrong with that I don't know just
seems like pretty familiar means that
you'll be you're into dynamite you use
dynamite a lot well oh there you know
what I was picturing he sort of looks
like as like if Vincent Price went
straight like it's like you know I'm
done with the acting game I'm going to
get into dynamite now he's probably a
little bit older than you know he is
when we are in the story this is Big
John so uh he keeps building up his
business and by 1972 he's a millionaire
okay he has three businesses and 26
employees
he buys Elizabeth a restaurant to run so
things are just rolling okay things are
it's the best best so this is the part
of the story normally when you just
gotta savor the moment because it's all
about to go terror no and Dave denies it
okay he owned three Mercedes but
unfortunately lost his license for
speeding so much oh so he bought an
airplane better that's better
and afer he would fly from job site to
job site doing crazy low altitude stunts
sometimes with the boys Johnny and Jimmy
in the plane okay he liked to buzz
water-skiers on a local lake or fly
under highway overpass whoa what is he
doing so he's a stuntman who's not being
filmed I mean he's got clearly has some
I don't give a [ __ ] what's happening hey
Johnny
Jimmy whatever your last name is let's
get this water scared and when we're
gonna go under the 405 so uh so yeah
it's a that's a weird thing and everyone
kind of gets to know him
no no a lot of times if a guy flies
planes under bridges people figure the
guys don't I'm gonna know this man
so at home he enjoyed working on
inventions just like us okay he was
always working with wires and a
smoldering out in his workshop
so this man has a soft spot for dynamite
oh and now he's getting involved in
wires and welding and okay so his
hobbies are great sniffing around what I
could call a potential issue he had good
ideas but didn't have enough patience
it was offbeat often beaten to patents
by other people
okay the marriage was not good okay they
both drank and often and they fought
yeah okay sure I think that was ever in
the 70s now yeah
Big John thought Elizabeth was having
affairs okay he said she was a
nymphomaniac and using the restaurant to
bang dudes in know like ozark but with
banging they said also but then don't
buy her a restaurant but there's still
like issues you know what you got to do
Big John get rid of that restaurant yeah
it's your marriage for her part
Elizabeth would take off for days at a
time
you can imagine where he was coming up
with your [ __ ] other dudes thing it's
like when she goes out on a Monday and
comes back on a Thursday still I'm gonna
have to say David that's not the
restaurants fault I feel like it's all
the restaurant no way no way yeah this
is what happens when you open a
restaurant yeah order the 109 you get to
spend a week with the woman who runs it
there's just one item on the dessert
menu oh yes Liz yes Liz cream I'm coming
with you go to Aspen with you you
ordered
Big John made Mary okay this is my
restaurant
we need to be back by Thursday okay
Big John made Johnny and Jim work in the
restaurant at night and summers they
work landscaping they would actually
have to sleep with the crew at night
okay what that like they wouldn't go
home at night when they're landscaping
they would sleep I'll tell you who
respected the guys the crew the crews
definitely like these all right I'll
tell you what these guys sir
they might be the boss's kid but I like
the buzzes kids so he he would give them
a haircut just once a year yeah that's
fair right after school ended sure he
would shave their heads completely with
clippers sure and then they go out to
work in the summer and their heads would
burn and blister in the Sun sure okay
I guess they didn't have hats any there
was the one time when people don't have
hats
yeah on the show so at no point is he
doing that as some sort of psychological
thing or is he just not learning oh you
know it'd be a probably better shave
their heads in September
I'm sure it's when they're head back oh
boy yeah so he also beat them good okay
good
when we have clarity so that's good with
belts electric cables boots coat hangers
whatever he had he'd roll into the room
in the middle of the night while the
boys were sleeping and just attacked
Johnny
once when Jimmy was 6 he put his elbow
on the table during a meal and Big John
punched him in the face knocking out
four teeth which is which is a bigger
etiquette foul but you know what Dave of
course has his back well
is he gonna put his elbow on the table
yeah I'll tell you what he's probably
not gonna do is put his elbow on the
table are you he's probably not gonna
use his elbow for anything anymore
yeah he's mean yeah that's all part of
the magic of Big John's training how
come you weren't an elbow pad on your
right elbow Johnny I don't want to talk
about it
Johnny started drinking at 12 and
smoking pot at 14 those by the way in
England standard numbers for yeah it's
not no come on it really isn't
I've seen your country yeah all right he
[Applause]
Johnny turned his rage on Jimmy who
would then turn to his parents for
protection at that point Big John would
beat up Johnny
and then afterwards scream at Jimmy for
being a snitch Wow how do you teach both
sides of that if he is I know he's
taking the care of both ends what did
you tell him ah no you don't tattle on
people yeah otherwise they'd get beat up
Big John hated snitches sure yeah sure
so Elizabeth filed for divorce in
November 1970 what about the situation
was she not digging there was no no
issues she had I don't know but she
moved into a trailer buying the house
oh that's okay where you going you're
divorced
yeah Big John sold the landscaping
business and started flying to Lake
Tahoe to gamble there's just a lot of
bad moving mm-hmm there's a lot of storm
clouds yeah in July 1975 Elizabeth
pulled one of her disappearing tricks
again but this time it was different
because she was found dead three days
later in a field behind the house oh boy
so she actually go very far mmm okay so
now it's taking a turn shift I'm
wondering if she's got elbows yeah great
guy just shows up I don't know who did
it but this she doesn't have elbows
though whoever hates elbow whoever did
this was obsessed with elbows god damnit
elbows in stitches so she had a lethal
combo of volume and booze nurse
in the corner rule that is suicide but
there was one issue yeah that that's the
map to a good time yeah that's a yeah
she only drank vodka and her stomach was
full of whiskey and a bottle was not
found hmm so what are what is mmm well
she but chugged whiskey and they threw
the bottle
Big John did what anyone does after his
ex-wife dies after the funeral he walked
around the house cutting her out of all
the photos in front of the kids hey John
what do you uh what how how you doing
man he grievant and then he took her
ashes out into the yard and just dumped
them in the yard her ass oh the ashes of
the pictures no just ashes of her her
ashes
wait her ash this is post cremation no
it's pre cremation so yeah I said he
just dumped it in the yard which he not
usually you have a better sort of way to
get rid a [ __ ] no I've always said I
want to be I want to be dumped in the
garden closest not a garden I just you
just I mean the garbage yep did I say
garden yeah garbage as a garden yeah if
you leave it long enough life will grow
so so he started spending a lot of money
and dressing very well he took the
gambling up a notch he liked Harvey's
wagon wheel casino in state line Nevada
it's a great spot Harvey's wagon wheel
is great one of the best yeah if you get
we go there on a day when harves there
oh he's handing out wagon wheels thank
you hey you have a good time my friend
you will have a good time
Harvey's was one of the first casinos
built in state line a town on the south
shore of Lake Tahoe in the Sierras on
the border of California Nevada sure it
was opened by Harvey grouse and his wife
in 1944 mister mrs. grose yep across the
street was Harrah's his main competition
Tahoe took off as a gambling location
and soon Harvey was killing it at
Harvey's Big John was treated as a
big-time
gambler Harvey's gave him the best room
for free he started to get his own suite
every time okay
he knew the staff he was invited to stay
at Harvey's ranch Wow what I was gonna
ask what's VIP life at the wagon wheel
right stay at Harvey's ranch yeah
and they even let him fly Harvey's
helicopter once okay I don't know does
he have a license I guess there's a
question he's got the plane license but
not a helicopter because he can fly a
plane so they were like we'll try the
helicopter from what I can read the air
and he goes take over that kind of deal
oh that was one of those so that's how
you teach your kid yeah it's exactly
you're at a parking lot you teach a kid
how to drive a little that's how I teach
my kid to drive a helicopter fly one
yeah yeah okay whoa figure it out quick
you know what I mean
no he's eight he's got it okay so with
this awesome treatment John Big John was
spending more and more time in Tahoe the
boys had to take care of themselves well
it's like they could do a better job you
know why don't we not beat each other
and we get haircuts whenever how about
that fun little wrinkle
one day delivery Chuck's just showed up
eight thousand in canned food and one
2,100 pounds of beef in another what
three entire steers and four Lambs
what's 200 pounds of hot dogs
anything perishable put it all in the
walk-in a walk-in freezer they had well
Big John told the boys there was enough
food to last them three years and took
off the state line for a month I mean
what was anticipated mother I used to
leave you Cheetos very much the same Big
John fell in love again okay with a
helicopter April 1976 he married an
18-year old waitress from the restaurant
he's brought from the wagon wheel
restaurant yeah she's no anymore cuz she
got she's right now her ashes are in the
art she's gone yeah
so 76 he was born in 22
for sure she's 18 sure that's cool
yeah there's a lot to talk about for
some reason the marriage only lasted a
year what I know good lord
then he started dating another waitress
Joan Williams moved in we get to see her
yeah oh okay that's it that's the only
picture I could find her well I like
that she's her purse is enormous she's
got a book likes books that might be
yeah so she's a probation officer or
something oh so she met okay so oh right
okay she moves in okay she liked
waitressing on weekends at the
restaurant but then had a real job
probation officer by week right wait
okay then a debt collector came around
one day I'm here for all the ham you
guys owe me nine pigs word is you got
200 pounds of hot dogs so we're here for
a hundred fifty pounds your hot dogs and
we're here for four of the pigs
listen we look we're with repo meets
we're here to do a job pal show us the
mother lode hey boss he said he's only
God like I have two hamburgers
[ __ ] that kid ain't need all that
hamburger looking at me fried weeks I'll
tell you what I smell hidden hot dogs
like I've never smelled them before this
kid sitting on a pile of cured beef hey
boss what you better not be quitting cuz
everybody's quitting I'm going over to
repo veggies
what the what is it with them I got a I
got like a digestive problem we all hid
look look I just the older I get the
harder it is leave me I sign the right
payroll company I'm gonna be paying you
guys for the love of God give a man five
years to find a payroll company well he
feeds you I don't wanna get paid in
Hamlisch how about this take a lamb
sleep on it I don't want a pickle I've
had like five lamb take away I don't
have a walk-in fridge jcalahan so
they're all packed in take and the ones
that don't come there's meat just piled
on top of my fridge that's called alpaca
that's not what that is man this is
supposed to be a cash economy this is
not a matter how mad I am at this I
don't even know what that means
Helen left a month ago and Matt over so
turns out Big John had bounced a couple
of checks to Harvey's was I really want
a picture that his main currency now is
just beef or some sort of food I mean
nine hundred hot dogs who should I make
that out to so he owed about $1,000
which he handed over when the debt
collector came okay a few months later
the restaurant burned down okay okay
police suspected foul play okay Big John
got 300,000 in insurance money which he
quickly lost the blackjack tables okay
that Harvey's okay great he then sold
this house to Joan to pay off his debts
Joan is the part-time probation of whom
who lives with the right okay but even
that wasn't enough he still owed more
money so in 1979
Big John bounced fifteen thousand worth
of checks at Harveys the debt collector
came back Big Sean said he'd be up in
Tahoe soon he would pay off the 1,000 of
what he owed when he got there but he
did not do this okay what he did do was
go to state line and lease a condo near
Harvey's and hit the tables again okay
wait but where does he owe the money to
he's so he's going to Harvey's and
playing in RVs yeah so what's the
security like at Harveys well this is so
this isn't like a I don't think Harvey's
mobbed up at all you mean the wagon
wheels clean and this is a different
time uh-huh so I just think that maybe
they were like maybe he'll come around
it's Harvey like you know they'd already
gotten so much money from him that maybe
like now they would just cut you off
alright I don't know if was like that
back then
right yeah maybe they just weren't
talking about it I'm sorry the heart is
just life at the wagon wheel yeah this
is a family joint it's a wagon for the
wagon wheel so he keeps getting gamble
there
but life is no longer being kind to Big
John his health is failing okay he had
two different ulcer surgeries and
started drinking Maalox like water
no Maalox it's a chalky water I don't
think they have it anymore
they do do they well my dad was a guy
who you know relaxes right yeah so my
dad would drink it like water too it's
like liquid tums or yeah it's well a
great suggestion ulcer I actually I like
to do a makers and Maalox which is on
the rocks it's kind of like a whiskey
White Russian little Maalox little
makers mark two ice cubes uh-huh
stir that up drink it right away so it
doesn't congeal into a hard concrete oh
yeah it's tasty it was yeah or you know
I'll do a peptone vibe sometimes for a
month yeah Maalox it was a thing back
then people just drank a lot of it sure
and alcoholics especially and they would
sometimes mix it with their actual oh
girl oh they really would yeah oh my god
this is a little minty right yeah yeah
oh that's why you gotta have a Maalox
Jupiter why I would get the creme de
menthe and just pour it in and double
the mint you know little Bailey's and
Maalox mmm get yourself a little Bay
locks and the spring of 1979
Big John was diagnosed with abdominal
cancer okay he was put in the hospital
with acute gastrointestinal bleeding
okay but after he still went and gambled
spending two or three weeks every month
in Tahoe gambling to make back what he
had already lost okay so he's okay he's
a plan does he have a plan of gambling
to make back what he lost sorry so his
plan is to continue to gamble and he's
gambling to make back right II lost the
plant oddly this doesn't work this
doesn't work no that's shocking and then
he shows up at Harveys on New Year's Eve
weekend and demands a room yeah I need a
room he's with a woman who's trying to
show off to that he's a big-time that's
how you do it
that's how you show off have nothing set
up have no reservation just show up and
demand but he used to be able to do that
yeah
still he does the deal now Wow he's not
getting sweets at the wagon wheel no
more no the manager put him up in his
usual suite okay but soon after the
manager came back and said the couple
had to leave the suite because there was
another guest who needed it okay sure
he's getting kicked out of his regular
suite yeah and he has put in a tiny room
that they could barely walk around the
bed it he got bumped yeah seriously but
yeah he's obviously furious the woman
said to Big John quote I thought you
were a big shot I am a this is when he
has to just take a look at the window
ago I was a big shot this looks out at
the vacant lot of the wagon wheel they
used to call me Big John used to cut not
only was a big shot they used to call me
Big John which is why I've got the big
room not this goddamn closet hello
dammit I've become a midsize job Big
John was 58 years old died of cancer and
had now been totally humiliated so he
came up with a plan the terror always
always bad words on the show and they
don't probably know I can see a little
while later Jimmy shows up Jimmy shows
up at the wagon wheel no Jimmy shows up
at Johnny's house Johnny's moved out of
the house I think I said that yeah
Johnny's now 19
that's Jimmy we're looking at that's
Jimmy okay Johnny is now 19
he's a pothead and a roofer okay sorry
roofer it says something about the times
we live in when now that to me means
that it oh my god what these are the
guys yeah these are sons look a little
Shaun Cassidy action going yeah look at
that like it's almost like if you said
give me a picture from the late 70s
truly so on the right Johnny is always
high he grows pot to smoke and sell
right so he grew so in other words he
deals pot he's tan he's rocking a thin
little mustache yeah both are actually
yeah as a final touch he drove a van
with a sticker that read when the vans
arrived no no no no naka
welcome to stereotypes fans for sale but
that's probably I mean that truly is
probably the heyday for that slogan oh
yeah like this is before that's like
when people would be like oh man that's
hilarious and it's amazing when the van
mad that's hilarious because that means
sexist man that's hilarious no no these
time I'm a wrestling or playing ball or
whatever I told you guys I'm doing
crunches for the last time I like to
work out okay another sticker inside on
the dashboard said ass grass or cash
nobody rides for free yeah yeah man
that's right what do you pay Dave let's
say you get in those you're out like
four hot dogs no I don't how come I
gotta eat them with the lights off and I
can't chew on Saturday nights
Johnny race motorcycles okay Jimmy hated
Johnny okay barely saw each other
anymore I think they hadn't seen each
other in like three years at this point
well it definitely looks like one of
them was just like you know what I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go a corporate route
and the other ones like tennis for sure
tennis so Jimmy on the Left Jimmy is
different he's 18 he's smart he was in a
high school program for the Brainiac
kids lives with his dad very you know
you don't need to tell people about the
Brainiac classes so we're in the
Brainiac class that's not you absolutely
no I was in all of them right mom
I got homeschooled she'd always yeah I
gradually in the garage for the smart
kids yeah yeah you fed me rabbit heads
you remember yeah yeah Jimmy said quote
Big John sent me to tell you he needs
your help
Jimmy explained the plan okay Big John
was going to extort a million dollars
from Harvey's by building and planting a
bomb in the casino what okay okay
keep going boy obviously insane the boys
ended up laughing about it thinking it
would never happen but things got worse
for Big John in March the IRS said he
owed thirty thousand dollars
so sorry just to be clear Johnny is
planning on building a bomb inside of
Big John Big John is not Johnny okay
right the boys are talking about it
they're the boys the boys talking about
it and they laugh about it they're like
that'll never happen and the one thing
we can agree upon is that if Dad were to
build a bomb inside of the casino that
would be madness yeah so then he find
Big John finds out he was the rs.30000
okay and he starts talking about killing
himself a bomb in a casino we'll do that
then in June Jimmy called Johnny to tell
him Big John had found the dynamite he
needed for the bomb but okay quite an
update from the last time when you were
like imagine anyway before I go dad has
all the dynamite to build the bomb he
won't shut up about wait are we doing
dad's dad's gonna do it I got a run
though I'm dealing pot at this event but
I got a run but ya know dad has all the
dynamite to build the bomb inside the
wagon wheel because the IRS is coming
after him all right I'll talk to you
okay take care so he didn't I found I
mean he knew where it was where I just
he just needed to steal it were they
hiding it or he just located where
there's enough dynamite located where
there's enough dynamite okay the boys
are still terrified of Big John and
agree to help him wow that's a new level
of fear they thought he would get caught
if he tried to get the bomb inside
Harvey's so nothing would actually
happen yeah I guess let's not say
anything
there's no way I'll get a bomb inside of
the casino so one night Johnny picked up
Big John and Jimmy in his van and they
drove into the mountains to the Helms
the options are cash to the Helms Creek
hydroelectric construction project they
were blasting four miles of tunnels in
the mountains and Big John had scoped it
out and security was not great the day
he went there he just walked in and
looked around and nobody said anything
okay
much different time with explosives and
didn't that happen in the White House
this week
so that book got written right just like
act like you belong just like hey I'm
gonna take a bunch of dynamite say
tomorrow boys happen sure enough they
got there they just drove through the
gate yeah they drove to a Shack that was
marked danger explosives this is where
the explosives are they cut the lock on
the shack they filled the van with boxes
of dynamite and blasting caps how is it
that they're able to get all this like
it's liquor at a country club that's
closed dynamite is those guys taking the
dynamite they're supposed to take the
dynamite I don't know but I don't want
to be rude man yeah yeah after the left
they drove the whole thing to about an
hour
nobody said away okay so I think that
one's dad gets to the casino there's no
way they'll be that polite there the
whole thing's just like nobody wants to
be rude look like that guy's building
the bomb yeah but when people show up
and look like they're supposed to do
stuff people like I supposed to be doing
that is part yeah do you enlist taking
dynamite yeah so they end up stealing 18
case that's a Beverly Hills Cop is based
on yeah okay give God which is a true
story yeah it's a great documentary
third one falls apart
they stole 18 cases of dynamo which was
a thousand pounds of explosive [ __ ]
imagine how much the van was just like
sagging in the back it's no joke what he
got in there just dynamite where do you
think they got it from I mean I don't
want to be rude oh they put the boxes in
the walk-in freezer which had been
purchased to hold all the meat well I
had a feast that the Three Stooges come
over someone's eating dynamite thinking
it's a hot dog that's for sure
the local paper ran a story about the
theft but no one seemed to care that
much okay sure
Johnny's girlfriend noticed though she
had been there when Jimmy came over to
talk about the plan and she immediately
broke up with Jeff
okay okay so Jimmy so we have the first
person in the story with sense right so
Johnny's girlfriend who was there when
they were joking around yeah
now put you two together I was like oh
my god they still thought I'm out of
here
baby wait once he tries to build it in
the casino they'll say something I'm
gonna get it in oh my god why won't
anyone understand that someone will stop
him it just can't be anyone uh Big John
was suddenly very happy okay yeah he was
working in his shop every day welding
and smoldering probably whistling away a
project you know I don't never mind I
have a male accent Jim
two weeks later he had welded two
rectangular boxes together using
quarter-inch steel so there's a large
box that could fit all the dynamite in
it cool and then it's 26 inches high 24
inches wide and 45 inches long okay the
second box is smaller and he welds it on
top of the first one and that's where
like the brain of the operation is sort
of like the carry-on and checked back
like the carry-on and check back that's
exactly how my mind works that's that's
a gap into my mind Palace thank you
really is really great thank you really
great mind it's really great oh
absolutely
so it had eight separate fusing
mechanisms good if any of them were
triggered the bomb would explode if
someone tried to drill outside the bomb
would explode if someone tried to
unscrew the screws on the top of the
boxes the bomb would explode the lids
also had pressur pressure switches so if
someone took off a lid the bomb would
explode so he's get the box was flooded
he'd rigged it with a floating device
from a toilet which would cause the bomb
to explode if someone tilted the box the
Box the bomb would explode if someone
tried to insert something
between the two boxes the bomb would
explode and put in a timer and once the
timer was set there's no way to stop the
bomb okay so hey so he's literally
thought of everything yeah who's moving
this with him I don't want to go with
you just the whole thing is that we
can't get it right and don't tilt it at
all make sure the boxes don't separate
don't put anything in the holes
do not make new holes and don't press
the top and we just got to sneak it into
the middle of the wagon wheel I mean
basically he built a bomb that could not
be disarmed right that's so the kids
still operate a gun to be no one will be
no one does someone has to say I mean
come on
I think there's I think they're just
terrified of him it sounds like that
might be the culprit the whole time so
the plan was to put the bomb in Harvey's
and give them information on how to move
the bomb if they gave money right so
they get the ransom then he provides
some information how to move the woman
then they could take it like out into
Lake Tahoe right blow it up with the
bottom lip doll or something yeah do it
so Big John worked on the bomb through
the summer I do love that he has his
little project I know he's happy to be
back there listening to CCR just smokin
right what about what about looking at
this as a guy is able to escape from his
cancer I'm having quite a I'm having
quite a Renaissance summers nothing
wrong with the project I'm finding me
again Big John
he works on the bathroo this summer
Johnny and Jimmy didn't want to have
anything to do with it but they were
also too scared of Big John not too Joan
typed up the ransom note cool so that's
good
she let Jimmy read it but only after he
put gloves on first sure so she's a
mother figure yeah for sure this is
before they were cutting out of
magazines that guy flipped the script
Big Time magazine cut guy that guy
people were like well that's what we do
from now on my god I mean there's what
we were sitting here typing we've been
writing with our left hands for a decade
I mean seriously the guy who did the
first match he's like I've known what he
was doing anything this is a
I want to kidnap so many people right
now or he's got writer's block and he's
like I just don't know if this is right
I might crazy maybe people will just be
like think it's gobbledygook over the
top yeah and then he drops it he's like
it's as good as I thought it's amazing
the sergeant pepper's of ransom note
before going bananas
I changed kidnapping oh my god what did
this guy you know what [ __ ] this okay
I'm just gonna tell everybody I did it
cuz it's so great I don't care about
getting away with it how they caught the
first guy you like the ransom note huh
you know it took a while my wrist was
starting to hurt a lot not easy to find
all those yf6 you know we found the why
Family Circus oh okay that may be
believe that that's amazing yeah all
right well you're under arrest for the
murder of nine people I don't care I
understand something
uh so on August 23rd they're doing a
little trial run with the bomb putting
it on a cart cuz that's how they're
gonna get into the casino right they're
gonna put on a cart and they're gonna
wheel it across the parking lot into the
casino okay like a like a what's that
was a cartoon yes this is called oceans
insane as they were doing it they were
using a rope the rope snapped one of the
wheels rolled over charged oh my god oh
my god oh my god what are you thinking
when anything goes wrong oh my god so
they're up stabs reel rolls over
Johnny's hand and he's furious and he's
done he screams quote I don't want
nothing more to do with it I'm out and
he leaves and then Jimmy says if he's
not gonna do it I'm not gonna do it
that's a great out that's a great excuse
Jimmy they go back the piggy backs a
great one yeah
he's like if my brother I hate can't do
it well I'm not gonna do it look I mean
this is crazy of it but he's leaving the
whole thing's falling apart because what
he started yeah go after him first so
Big John called two friends felon Terry
Hall and felon bill Brown okay both
felons okay yeah you said felons both
were big-time drinkers and out-of-work
okay so they need money
uh-huh like John told bill he had a job
that paid two grand
four days work okay each of them get two
grand for one day's work
sure the bill sets all they know though
that's right bill said quote whoo I got
to kill okay okay potentially yourself
but to come down here let's do this in
person so bill and Terry slammed the
beers they were drinking and headed over
to Big John's house let's get some
Maalox and then we'll head right over
Big John said he needed help delivering
machine to Harvey's
okay it's a bunch of hot dogs on the box
taking a little hottie
that's nice buffet afternoon night
that's classy that's nice that's nice
you know you got a bad reputation but
you're a pretty good guy thank you
that's nice not two meats they call me
meet me John sure they should work on it
a little longer maybe meet Johnny okay
all right now don't do any more Johnny
hot dogs Johnny huh Wiener job a stop
bitching God hot me no no Bobby hop me
Johnny dawn I don't even know have a cow
so these guys don't ask why they have no
questions about what they're delivering
or why they're delivering it that's what
they see I think this is all normal that
they're delivering a box of [ __ ]
sharing a machine as do they say yeah
did they get it doesn't they no point
they're like why would you give us two
thousand dollars to deliver a machine
like nothing has questions does he I
read this they're also wrong but still
you would think you you've got to run
them through the rules you've got to add
some oh he does he runs them through
okay so they're just like uh-huh okay
yeah okay so don't get what got it okay
yeah don't feel that understand all
right cool yeah don't separate them
understood okay yeah don't touch any of
the holes don't make any new holes okay
okay yeah don't touch the top too hard
okay yeah take it in the middle of
Harvey's don't do any of those things
okay yeah you got it okay boss yet two
grand today what are you gonna do huh
yeah okay don't look at it I got it okay
don't breathe on it that's fair no it's
understandable
all right well let's just do
the job huh Kenny Moe beer yeah let's
just say I'll tell you can I pour can I
put a beer on it yeah yeah oh you're
bright because of the pressure on the
right yeah and I can't get it wet right
okay yeah let's hit a hold a beer while
I'm pushing the thing yeah what's the
deal with that can we put it on
someone's back okay no okay all right
yeah let's do it let's do it
what drink the beer I'll put the basket
we'll put it on beer hats we'll put your
hats on okay here we go
okay so they leave at dusk Big John
drives because as as you do when you're
delivering a machine to exceed oh you
want to try through the night yeah well
you've got it you've got to drive
because the others like okay yeah so why
don't you drive okay we'll just go six
the whole time okay however you want to
do it you can't be like hey watch this
I'll just do a you you're like no
u-turns there ibly don't you turns so
they drink beers in the band the whole
time okay driving okay they drove all
night and arrived at 5:00 a.m. okay they
had breakfast and then they went to a
motel
Big John told Terry to get a room but
Terry was on parole so he couldn't
register a room under his name
out-of-state okay so he wrote a fake
name down on the card they stayed in the
room until that night okay
they drank and watch TV fun Big John
went out at 2:30 a.m. and told the guys
to pick him up at a nearby airport that
happens when you're delivering a machine
to a business so I'm gonna go out okay
yeah it's 2:30 go ahead okay yeah and
then you guys are gonna pick me up at a
5:00 a.m. at the air but okay yeah okay
don't stop just slow down enough so I
can jump on the side okay yeah don't do
a full stop okay got it yes you can jump
on the side and get in okay you don't go
ahead and take the Machine over to the
yeah we'll take the machine that we
can't get wet look at or put anything on
top of yeah okay great okay yeah alright
see you guys in a bit all right yeah no
problem yeah I don't remember my name is
different here oh yeah yeah okay cool
all right they need to that's right
that's right Jimmy Benito okay all right
all right I guess we'll stay up all
night then yep
okay so at 4 a.m. they went to go
but the van wouldn't start oh boy
Big John came back and called the tow
truck and they got a jump and then the
van was running here yeah
what now that to keep it running okay
then he had Terry and Bill change into
blue overalls and they drove over to
Harvey's okay are there anybody and
anybody asking anything at any point
okay get naked in the van and put on
blue overalls okay yeah you got it
okay we got a ton of exits or anything
no one's as good question we've got to
choose some weed or something in our
mouths
should we call each other Appleseed how
do you want to handle it tell us what
the dough okay so he stopped and stole
license plates from another van on the
way okay so you've got a bunch of
license plates from that band put it on
this one okay yeah okay okay no problem
yeah you want we should help but you
want to do it all yourself okay great
you do it then okay they got to Harvey's
at 5:00 a.m. he's two guys bill and
Terry unloaded the box okay it was heavy
and hard to move oh boy don't move it
too much they put it on a dolly when
they got it to the doors a guy inside
Harvey's just let them in and guided
them over to an elevator
let me get that door for you gentlemen
there we go
move along now never said a word the guy
just never said a peep we think there's
hot dogs in here bill then went back to
the van and Terry took the palm up on a
dolly to the second floor like God just
you and gum now Terry wasn't super drunk
but he definitely had a lot of beer
Jesus he put now he's told he was told
where to put it
okay yeah so he puts it in a room on the
second floor he took off the overalls
okay he puts it he puts it down and he
puts it's got like I don't know if it
has wheels or what it has but he puts a
plywood underneath each I think it's a
wheel underneath each wheel okay and
that's how he sets it up okay as we
would do with the machine
are you gonna bring up a picture of a
dolly oh oh my God look at the little
box oh he's good it's got wheels bo yeah
it's got a little uh that that's the
actual thing yeah that's the bomb is
that what you were picturing the other
one okay just get a couple of us in here
what's the smile it's the woman still he
faces okay okay you got it boss
boy these people are gonna love all
these hot dogs that's right boys
so then as he had been told he takes off
the overalls and puts them in a Harvey's
bag
all right just gotta get naked and put
that closed in Harvey's bag and then
John and then John told him to do that
so he did it and then he went down the
stairs instead of the elevator and went
out through the casino main casino floor
and out the front door okay so he had
stuff on underneath the oh yeah it
closed okay
Big John Terry and Bill then drove off
okay
okay they bought more beer drank a
little bit and then stopped at a creek
to pee so Big John is probably keeping
them just drunk enough I think shot like
really throw a lot of flags on them i
100% think that he's keeping them nice
and buzzed yeah you know I was just
thinking have another beer okay I never
mind I really think that's what's going
on but on GG top so at the creek the
creek that they're peeing in while the
two guys are peeing
Big John throws the dolly into the creek
okay and for the first time okay well
the fella Terri I have a question hey
yeah why would you throw away a piece of
something I could sell for 20 bucks a
big journal you know we was just just
start talking as we was taking a leak in
the creek enough hey why'd you throw the
dolly in I mean about [ __ ] think of
all the things to me okay okay is it
just me or is it weird to throw
something with wheels away so never mind
having to leave a robot in a room so Big
John tells them they had just put a bomb
in Harvey's okay okay okay okay thanks
big bags BJ
and bill and Terry are shocked okay you
have to look but you have to be like boy
I'm an idiot
we are idiot we are definitely idiot I'm
looking back now and I'm thinking
there's so many times I'll seat yourself
there's so many don't lead yourself up
how are we to know anything stuff arias
was taking playing oh he was like change
your clothes of course it was a little
strange - don't look anybody in the eye
of course it was strange that he
demanded no eye contact
don't shake the park of course there's
not chill the box - look at the slugs
where all the parts go there was a lot
of shake it don't put worse of course
but how are we to know that that's
anything are they then the whole thing
when we check the hotel in our different
names yeah no that's drunk all night he
went at 2:30 in the morning
don't miss the license plate on the car
come on my dad just do that all the time
on family road trips don't beat yourself
up don't Monday Morning Quarterback
yourself is so goddamn stupid it was a
nice no he's very kind very shrewd
[ __ ] thing though this beer is so
good yeah and I'll tell you I think we
can fish that dolly out and make a quick
25 time feel free you know what I mean
like working with you ABC always be Big
John to alleviate their fears said he
had left he had had he had Terry leave a
note drop it on the floor next to the
bomb telling Harvey's to get everyone
out of the building so no one was gonna
get hurt he's like no there'll be no one
in the building of the bomb goes off
because he left to post it near it well
he left and he left it no it's a it's a
three-page note just telling people what
to do instructions also get on out of
the building that doesn't that sound
like he cares well he cares about the
people I guess
does he well Rossi just have the bomb go
off yeah but I don't like what I mean if
you walk into a room and you have these
two steel boxes yeah and there's three
pages of loose-leaf which one are you
gonna go home I'm gonna take a look at
ol a letter I got to do the card first
you're gonna love this story huh boy on
the way back bill and Terry got
completely [ __ ]
okay about a half-hour later a Harvey's
worker noticed the strange box in the
telephone exchange room of the casino
okay
it was on metal legs bounced on pieces
of plywood he went downstairs to get
security the security guard had just
taken a training course oh hey on
leather bombs
okay he went in the room he took one
look saw the letter on the floor and
told everyone who had gathered and was
looking at the box to back away
called the sheriff the sheriff arrived
the sheriff in the security guard poked
the envelope with a broomstick
wait are you wait a minute from behind
the metal box no no wait okay wait so
this guy has just been trained and he's
actually doing the right thing until
people see him poking a letter and
they're like he has been trained
he thinks the letters a bomb he's been
trained just trained and of course on
letter bombs has he he has are we sure
yes okay so he's poking it from behind
the guard the thing that was let me get
on top of this box and I'll poke it with
a broom harder they poked it then they
realize it's not a bomb inside the
envelope or three pages okay the
security guard took one page and he
leaned on the bomb while he read the
page is going on there's all right tell
the cop who was reading another page hey
my page has something interesting about
the box it pointed at the bomb and said
quote that's a bomb you know it reversed
I had you could see how I could do that
though because look at the letter it was
a very suspicious envelope now this big
box here that's nothing but main to that
envelope look weird funny metal ottoman
mm-hmm so the building is evacuated it's
Labor Day weekend so everything is sold
out all over town
the FBI comes the parking lot at that
point was full of old people in their
pajamas kids without shoes people
thinking total disarray being loaded
onto buses sure the security guards are
trying to figure out how to lock a
casino front door that had been opened
24 hours a day for 17 years what Jesus
Christ there's no lock on this thing oh
boy there's not even a way to close it
oh boy we need the opposite of Houdini
right now II the FBI and local bomb
squad were taken aback by how well the
bomb was built look at this none of the
bomb squad guys had ever seen anything
like it there appeared to be no way in
the letter quote stern warning to the
management and bomb squad do not move or
tilt this bomb because the mechanism
controlling the detonators will set it
off at a movement of less than point
zero one of the open end Richter scale
oh my god no but it sounds good yeah but
so what
the bomb squad guy was look that's total
[ __ ] but but what I mean I'm sure
this is where we're going but like what
are you if you read that list of stuff
you can't do you like oh wait he says
don't don't try to flutter gasps the
bomb there's a float switch and an
atmospheric pressure switch set at two
six zero two three three zero both are
attached to detonators do not try to
take it apart the flathead screws are
also attached to triggers warning I
repeat do not try to move disarm or
enter the bomb it will explode okay and
meanwhile Terry had to drop that letter
my god fingerprints are probably all
over the eases it said the bomb was
packed with a thousand pounds of TNT
which would wipe out harvey's and do
damage to Harrah's across the street
there were three separate timers quote
this bomb can never be dismantled or
disarmed without causing an explosion
not even by the creator
god I am baffled it looks like even the
screws have some sort of wire on it and
I boy I don't even know how to how
offensive visit your son thinks that
God's a man oh boy no I'd actually Dave
I don't okay
how about that Jack so I believe it's
the Divine Mother a tentacled B mmm the
letter asked for three million in used
hundred-dollar bills to be delivered by
helicopter to a middleman okay wait
three million nan fresh novels delivered
to a middleman via helicopter okay more
details would come sure sure sure we
just got to have a couple of beers it
said the it said the details would come
by post office so I think that was also
[ __ ] was there a part be there just
like now they're in there oh [ __ ] we
need to hire a middleman after the money
has received the instructions would be
given to disconnect two timers so the
bomb could be moved somewhere it would
explode without harm okay quote there
will be no extension or renegotiation
then transaction has to take place
within 24 hours I mean this is a pretty
good I mean he's done a pretty good job
hmm yeah okay make sure that's clear
they x-rayed the box and the yep it was
full of explosives and very very complex
it seemed they were looking at the
largest improvised bomb in US history it
was sort of scripted the FBI set up a
control center people drove down and
parked nearby to watch of course so
words out it's on the news so everyone's
driving now to check it out yeah so our
IQs always kind of been hovering around
the same area it's just that we now have
access to more terribleness well when i
was in i think i'm till the server when
i was in college there was a plane crash
where a guide shot up shot a pistol on a
plane and the plane exploded and we were
like i was like fifty minutes holy [ __ ]
let's drive up there check that out oh
my god and then we're walking there and
we're not walking to the car we're here
and there's body parts over
we should should not wash it out of here
we were just thinking like it would just
be like you know you could upload it to
YouTube oh that's so glad we Logan did
not do that
mm-hmm you don't think about that stuff
hey why you scarred forever oh yeah this
good idea well so the FBI then army bomb
squad was sent the FBI 725 guys
scientists came from Laurens little more
lap like all these people need these
people well you do need experts like
they do want as many experts as they can
get but too many looks I say they have
too many colors that's fair they spent
hours inspecting the bomb every possible
way by 3:00 p.m. the National Guard had
set up a quarter mile perimeter around
Harvey's Highway 50 was shut down boy
Harrah's was loving this oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah well they showed they showed or
they didn't show but I saw pictures of
like people sleeping in the hallway at
Harrah's because there were no hotel
rooms anywhere Wow
okay so the National Guard says the
perimeter the highways closed down there
on 10th at night they went to see Harvey
gross about the ransom and what he
wanted to do he was told the best thing
to do would be to blow up the bomb where
it was moving it even with the
instructions could cause it to go off
and kill the guys moving it Harvey said
quote there's no way I'm paying these
sons of [ __ ] any money okay so he's
okay he's a casino owner okay
so Harvey is digging his heels in big
john got back home late that afternoon
though Johnny Jimmy said they wouldn't
carry the bomb Big John made them swear
they would help with the ransom
collection okay so they're back in it
okay now they tried to back out but Big
John got angry and told them they had no
choice
boy the power you have over those two
guys they agreed Big John told them to
take two strobe lights he'd stolen okay
D masks and jackets sure sure
a three you guys are gonna join the
Insane Clown Posse
okay you what other gonna call Juggalos
in the future boys ready to go to a rave
a 357 revolver a 22 a 303 rifle a box of
ammo and a 12-volt motorcycle battery
that would be for the strobe lights okay
sure sure they put all the stuff in Big
John's gold Volvo big guy overlooked how
could you have a less conspicuous car
ding so Big John and Joan drove her
Toyota Celica
well that's Joan still in the mix yeah
yeah she's not she's in this yeah
Jimi and Johnny followed in the Volvo
they dropped Joan at an airport near
Sacramento sure and then the men drove
in the Volvo to a remote clearing in the
mountains above Lake Tahoe okay Jimmy
and Big John got out plan was to use the
strobes to signal a helicopter that
would be flying in right sure and when
the pilot landed they were overly not an
epileptic pilot be disasterous
when the pilot landed they would
overpower him and Big John Wooden like
John would then take the helicopter
which he didn't know how to fly he only
knew how to fly planes but he had flown
one but not taking off he would take the
helicopter and fly so Jimmy and the
money 40 miles away
and then Johnny would be waiting there
with a Volvo and then Jimmy and the
money would get in the Volvo but John
would fly to meet Joel at the airport
near Sacramento inside a volcano and
then they'd all go home and right done
of course boom boom boom back in time
for the Walton can you see how that
could not go well at all well it sounds
like the explosive device was not the
only improvised thing all right and then
he lands you guys beat the [ __ ] out of
him I with no experience shall fly it
and then I'm gonna go meet your mom I
would like you to start addressing her
his mom but Big John forgot the battery
pack for the strobe lights oh my god
what so where are you where are you just
light your lighter fast so they tried to
steal one from a closed gas station so
they drive back away from they're about
to get
million dollars and they're stealing
there's shoplifting they're trying to
love that they're up in the mountains
there's nothing around so they drive
from the clearing they get to this first
gas station it's closed obviously if
you're the dad and you boys had to bring
a battery you built what they're calling
the craziest bomb they've ever seen he
forgot the battery not that big John
yeah you forgot to put it in the car
mm-hmm
you want to know the worst part I did
remember wallet and I thought that's
what I forgot god damn it so he tries to
break into like a car at a gas station
but the guy who runs a gas station lives
there and he comes out with a dog and a
gun and they run off so then they'd then
the only thing to do is they drive 30
miles down the mountains she's a
Placerville and buy one at a Shell
station they buy a battery at a Shell
station hmm
and now we're offering two packs if you
wanna actually take advantage you can
get two packs this actually happens no
show the guy they were like hey man we
need a battery in the guys yeah well
tell me what kind of car you have I got
he's they're like we don't care just
give us one is no one get this right do
you have a Volvo or a Volkswagen or do
you battery well now you say that but
what I'm noticing that the Duracell has
that the energizer don't I want our dear
battery okay now let me tell you about
why I would go with energizer and then
I'm gonna tell you why you should go
with the single and not the double okay
right now we're running a special okay
well you can get two energizer batteries
for five dollars but in your situation
it sounds like you're not hard up for
two actually I'm sort of thinking you
maybe want to go now that I'm pitching
it to you I'm thinking well maybe do go
Duras oh well now let me tell you why
let me tell you let me tell you the lady
in line she's snoring now hold on ma'am
you will wait your turn now there is an
ever ready
the third option that I have not even
revealed until this moment they just
throw money the guy I take them out okay
so they drive back now they're obviously
way behind
thirty miles out of the way by the time
Johnny dropped off Jimmy and Big John at
the clearing it's now midnight
what is the helicopter pilot just doing
loops
okay the helicopter was told to be
waiting at the Tahoe Airport at 11 p.m.
to wait for instructions now that's
where he had gone at 2:30 a.m. right
hotel right so the guys there the
helicopter guy supposed to be there and
he's told that the instructions would
come either by a payphone or be driven
by taxi but the pilot is late because it
turns out no one in the area wanted to
help the FBI and let them use their
helicopter okay none of the local
agencies stepped up Wow so the FBI had
to fly in a helicopter from Los Angeles
takes time so adding a minute so right
as the pilot landed the helicopter
everyone's freaking out the phone starts
ringing Wow okay it's to 1208 a.m. and
it's Johnny on the other end so Johnny's
dropped him off he's driven to a
payphone
sure Johnny uses southern accent at
first great how you doing and then
immediately dropped it the next line I
only practice how you doing [ __ ] how you
doing how you doing are you ready for
the instructions wait what
hey you doin the instructions go is this
he told the pilot the instructions were
in the phone booth and that he had three
minutes on the underside of the phone
booth the pilot found a taped envelope
he hustled to the helicopter and gave
the directions to know there could be a
letter bomb yeah thank you mm-hmm so you
grunts helicopter gives the directions
to another FBI agent who's hiding behind
the seats with a submachine gun okay he
is an X watt leader now at the FBI the
copilot seat had three bags on it stuff
with bundles of newspaper that looked
like three million in $100 bills but
they just had like a hundred on the
outside I mean again these are like
think these are like movie tropes but
that probably we're like this is still
early in that yeah well I checked the
top layer all hundreds this checks out
for sure
the SWAT leader reads the instructions
so he hands the know the pilot hands the
notes to the SWAT leader guy okay mmm
follow highway 50 West and after 50
minutes look for a strobe light land and
find more instructions taped to a tree
oh my god they must just be like this is
ridiculous now the FBI has other plans
okay high above this helicopter was a
Huey carrying a six man FBI SWAT team
the plan is for the first helicopter
with the SWAT leader to come down
they're gonna hit their lights
that's walk out of the submachine gun is
gonna jump out the door away from the
guys uh huh roll out
then put on night-vision goggles and
hunt down the guys doing the extortion
right and if that didn't work if that
didn't work they bring in the guys from
the Huey and just [ __ ] blast the [ __ ]
out of the place so the Huey is flying
above way above they can't even tell
okay okay now Big John and Jimmy waited
and they waited okay and again their
plan is to just beat the snot out of the
pilot okay they're planning on fists
against guns submachine gun sure for
sure and they wait and no halle
helicopter comes because the SWAT guy
had read the directions incorrectly and
the helicopters flying in the wrong
direction
I'm also an idiot just to be clear I to
him dumb I think our brain school all
right here we are
Bakersfield oh man so the pilot just
keeps circling wider and wider trying to
find this strobe light just be looking
for get there finally guess he's a
house-party
fare NER NER NER and man there it is
right down there drop me off I'll put on
the night-vision goggles and beat him up
finally gave up and just flew back to
Tahoe it was very cold
Big John used gun powder to start a fire
as he waited what
Oh that'll hate you Johnny stood around
waiting for four hours in the dark no
helicopter with his dad and brother came
okay
he finally drove to Joan the two of them
listened to the car radio where the
governor said there had been confusion
about the drop and they still wanted to
pay the ransom so the governor is just
on an open channel being like hello guys
yes ma'am we're still down he's trying
to reach the extortion okay
so Johnny Joe and Joan decided to drive
back to get Big John and Jimmy because
they know that they're just waiting
there someone's running out of gas
eventually but as they're driving Joan
slides off the road and crashed into an
embankment what so now Joan is bleeding
from her nose in her head they got the
two of them get in the Volvo and drive
towards Jimmy and Big John who they see
just walking down the middle of the
highway what is mean at any point as
someone just gonna admit this is going
horribly hey guys can we just take a
minute and say how bad we're doing I
think oh great I don't think it is we're
about to turn a corner so that's around
6 a.m. now so it's Wednesday August 27
it's light out now and they have no
money strobes really gonna take a hit
now Joan is still bleeding so they take
her to a Placerville Hospital okay Big
John told Johnny to call the Sheriff's
Office
and tell them to flip switch number five
and wait for more instructions practice
your southern accent now now if I was
just a dummy switch but he figured that
would buy the more time from the 24-hour
deadline 5 is a dummy switch at 7:00
a.m. they start the drive back home
Johnny was late for work at the roofing
company what's up he's speeding I was ok
so you know bombs I was throwing a rave
for a helicopter friend so he's speeding
so he's not gonna be late for work and I
California House officer pulls them over
and writes him a ticket
that's it at Harveys they're obviously
worried the deadline has come and gone
sure they figured the bomb to blow
at anytime every expert there has his
own idea on what to do and how to handle
it the leading one was to use explosives
to blow it up so you got to do to use
blow it up with a bomb so the idea is to
use this well-placed piece of brass that
I'm not going to go to the technical
things but the idea is that you blow it
in and it it's the fastest way to get
this thing in there and then it cuts off
a lot of wiring essentially like says it
severs the fusing mechanism it cannot
blow up so you shoot you basically shoot
shrapnel into the bomb hoping that it'll
cut but you're doing it like you're
you're purposely blowing it in a
direction or using a very specific sure
piece of metal sure I think this key
though you're sort of a bunch of water
on it yeah yeah that's good idea
put a little mylanta Maalox in it at
noon everyone there voted and agreed to
blow up the bomb and whoever voted for
pee-wee Herman ha ha we're not cool boys
okay Trump who said Trump oh my god
that's crazy all right let's focus
things that could happen a defensive
defense contractor in Las Vegas made the
brass piece and it was flown by
helicopter to tile we got this pilot
who's dying to fly this guy loves fly
he's bored
he loves it hey Jimmy how about you
don't fly to Texas this time for God's
sake one time the SWAT guy read the
directions wrong okay SWAT guy yeah
amazing wrinkle the best by the way the
pilot invented a SWAT guy who's been
with him a lot it's kind of like his
well is Harvey to be honest ironic
so at 3:10 p.m. the lead bomb dude
whoever he has positioned the explosives
and the brass piece okay around Harvey's
all tourists are lined up let's get
closer some are wearing boy
ready yeah these t-shirts I got bombed
at Harveys oh my god people are already
there are dudes selling shirts
out on the street
merchants already happened there already
did selling this shirts that say I
bombed at Harveys and people have all
got him on oh my god I need one of those
gamblers we're placing bets on what
would happen okay
okay that's the line what's the
over/under so as I said there are tons
of people waiting boy we're just people
staring at the hotel yeah well I always
think of that when there's that that
picture that tsunami and there's like oh
yeah there's that huge tidal wave and
there's like people like taking pictures
of it right before you know there is
something where you just you can't do
yeah I agree so deputy called out a
woman no it's on that guy - oh there's
nice sure a deputy calls out a warning
over PA of his patrol car the County
bomb squad guy said quote fire in the
hole and touched a second wire to a
battery
it was 346 p.m. he then said quote holy
[ __ ] but no one heard it because
harvey's was blowing up oh my god wait
okay the more that we were getting close
to it the more I was thinking shooting
brass inside of a bomb doesn't sound
that great and by the way it's just
because they hadn't heard from him they
were just like freaking out well but I'm
understandably like he didn't give a 24
hour notice yeah but still I think I
don't know I mean to me it seems like
the smartest idea but look nothing was
gonna work okay concrete and plaster
rain down fragments of wood metal and
glass spray out from both sides of
Harvey's a cloud of white dust came out
of the second floor enveloping the
building the crowd whooped now I
couldn't find I found I found a video of
them whooping at one point okay but then
I couldn't find it again but it's
literally people right all right
so people are super into it of course
they are explosion oh wow so it's done
so Harvey's has done
geez yeah it's it's no there's no joke I
mean he blew a boat so I can't wait for
the news to travel the big John about is
Wow
game over yeah we blew Tom okay
so cloud of white dust came out of the
second floor and enveloping the building
the crowd whooped a 5-story hole had
been blown out of the middle of the
casino it reached from the foot we're
still doing pie go guys we could still
do pie go we're still doing pie go in
the dime slots those are still working
he knows still going he knows still
going and we're still doing the Mai
Tai's two for once a five-story whole
been blown all the way from the fifth
floor to the basement toilets and TV
sets were dangling drywall clothing
sheets waters pouring from pipes five
minutes later
Jimmy called the sheriff's substation
just north of state line how you doing
quote if you still want the exchange
I'll call back in one hour
oh yeah I think that went pretty good I
think they definitely sound frazzled on
their end I think we just might have
gotten the upper hand gentlemen so I
apologize mother he's moved it ahead or
something I'm super drunk I mean I would
hate for you to be offended by his
behavior so so Jimmy when we're ready
dad Jimmy hangs up Jimmy and Big John
get into their car that they were
driving and because they're going back
to pick up John from the hospital that's
when they heard the news on the radio
okay
and Big John said quote well I don't
have anything to live for now oh so he's
taking it hard
yeah I'd say so but it was just months
of work this is all summer
yeah whole summer four nights later they
watched footage of the explosion in the
waiting room at the hospital oh my god I
mean now why
you know what stranger comes up you
believe that some fella apparently
wanted money for it yeah it's funny open
Big John watching it was pretty
impressed quote it worked pretty good I
say we go to Harrah's the day after Big
John called so they all throw home Big
John called Bill and Terry and told him
to come over to the house I've got some
interesting news they were very scared
went anyway
Big John started to tell them about his
new plan Oh No
to blow up Harvey's oh my god he's
boring Harvey's up again what is the
next day I was talking about blowing up
Harvey well gentlemen I realized we had
a bunch of flaws in the first plan and
then around 2:00 o'clock I went to bed
angry and I woke up at 4:00 a.m. and I
had a revelation we need to blow up
Harvey's we just we just again no but
right now we need to do it again hit him
where it's got a hole in it there's
still two-thirds of the building that
remains that I think is fair game
gentlemen and I'm proposing that we take
advantage of that now granted we're
gonna have to sneak in there with
another box probably won't be as good as
the one I spent all summer on but we'll
get in there let's get our hands in the
middle guys one turns out a bill and
Terry are super not interested so then
Big John gets mad and says if they told
anyone about what they'd done he would
have them killed now they were obviously
scared because they thought he killed
his wife so they're right not gonna do
anything two days later on Friday
afternoon enough debris was cleared from
around the hotel to open part of
Harvey's casino for gambling my god I
mean I cannot wait for Harveys to get
word on Part B you know no nobody you
didn't get the memo that's from two days
ago
no we fund a new one the old Lake Room
was intact and back in action and by the
way who's going
so I you wouldn't hit 14 but
unfortunately that piece of rubble made
it bounce to double zero sorry everybody
so I had a friend whose pants had a
cabin up near here and right after this
we went up there like a week later okay
we went up to the cabin and heat and he
liked to gamble so he drove to Harvey's
- two state line and gambled and we
stayed in like the kids area so it was
like a week later and Harvey it wasn't
Harvey's but was another place he
gambled right I mean if there's a time
when you're like what about not going to
stay alive yeah with the kids
yeah oh no they just got hit it's a lot
like roulette it's not gonna hit again
so a two hundred thousand dollar reward
for information was offered by Harvey
and the other casino owners none of the
witnesses could agree on what the
suspect look like then the manager of
the balla home motel near the airport
called he said two men driving a white
van checked in the day before the bomb
was found I'll never forget it it had a
really funny thing on the back it said
if this vans a-rockin don't come no no
if this vans a-rockin if this vans are
sucking don't come oh don't help don't
help don't help don't help don't help
come to me I'm [ __ ] ladies in this van
how about that was it that was it yeah
that was it how about that I think so if
the doors locked I'm masturbating that
was it yeah that was that was that was
the one sorry mother
he said the guys had asked for jumper
cables at 4 a.m. and checked out soon
after real professional gentlemen they
were but terry had given the wrong name
because he was on parole right he had
however oh no given the correct license
plate number smart Terry the DMV I don't
want to lie a bunch now the DMV
Department had an application for a
title transfer on file
meaning the van was in the middle of
being sold or whatever so they'd have
searched for it by hand which would take
a long time ok
forensic wasn't getting anything from
the crime scene they had a list of
several hundred suspects
and considered the IRA Iranian students
in the Mafia
they even hypnotized witnesses to try to
get details and that's a that's a great
movie right there after around a month
Jimmy was woken up by a noise in the
middle of the night boy it was Big John
he'd just come back from stealing
another dozen cases of dynamite the band
back together my guns feeling good again
I think we could do this for a while he
put by the way they put in no new
security measures up there so just give
a dynamite away so he put it in the
walk-in freezer a few days later he
asked it's all the same nothing changed
a few days later asked Jimmy to help him
move it and they drove a few miles to
the edge of town near Elizabeth brothers
farm ok his ex brother-in-law
right Big John had already dug a hole
there and they buried the dynamite
dynamite about 700 pounds of it ok
in October the hit on the license plate
came back from the DMV and it was one
John Burgess Johnny an FBI agent came to
Big John's house and asked about the van
John said it wasn't his Big John said it
wasn't his it was his sons good guy good
good daddy nice dad that's my [ __ ]
kid right that knucklehead
he's always talking about chilling a
coffin bomb nobody likes that Punk yeah
so he throws his kid under the bus
the FBI agents come back I think the
next day huh Oh like I said Johnny sold
it and just gone back to roofing so he's
everyone's back at their things
everybody really handle ok so he he
comes home or he comes to the house and
then Big John Jimmy and Johnny come up
with a plan or a story for the FBI it's
a good one so Johnny would say to the
FBI that he driven up into the mountains
to look for a place to grow pot and that
the van had stopped running ok so he
hitchhiked home
and went back to get the van after a few
days and who knows what the van was
doing while he was away Oh somebody went
seen the license plate bumper sticker
situation right what I like about the
plan is that this criminal returned the
van thank you like that when the FBI
agents came back Johnny gave them the
spiel so yeah and then I came back and I
was there so who knows what happened to
a Tuesday to Thursday no he had no idea
how it ended up at the hotel he said
when he came back to get the van one of
the door locks was open which was weird
by now that I think about it that is
kind of weird
also some cassettes have been moved
around which I would never do I keep
mine alphabetized and the ages told him
his story was [ __ ] ridiculous and
that he was clearly lying whoa gentlemen
hey we're all professionals here come on
boys he was now in the list of suspects
what what the cassettes by November ha
the Harvey's explosion investigation was
one of the biggest and most expensive in
FBI history but the FBI had nothing on
December 1st the investigation was
scaled way back you would now just be
handled in a small office in Carson City
by three agents so they think it's they
think they just got nothing it's [ __ ]
and it's over okay
Big John got into a fight with his ex
brother-in-law and dug up the dynamite
he rigged some of it under a wooden
bridge on the farm you could hear the
explosion all the crust so he's playing
it cool yeah you think that's a problem
Aaron no okay here the podcast in
January 1981 Johnny was served with a
subpoena to testify before a grand jury
in Reno Johnny went alone the jurors
listened to him Johnny was very casual
sure he didn't think they could prove he
was lying okay nothing came of it the
investigation was running on fumes on
May 13th 1981 after 18 million in
repairs Harvey's formally reopened okay
the reward was now at 500,000 and Big
John is making plans for his next score
he went to the new Harvey's to check it
out
can you imagine me security is that
bigjon you know I don't to be rude and
asking I mean there's no way he'd come
back he also checked out maybe doing
this at the Bank of America building in
San Francisco ok so there was an options
yeah the five hundred thousand reward is
what finally let a guy to call he had
dated a girl who told him what was going
to happen before it did okay her name
was Kelly Cooper
she was Johnny's ex-girlfriend who had
been there the first day right told the
plan okay
it was now on the full investigation
focused on John Burgess senior and
family they went they dug up everything
on the family the gambling history the
association with Harvey the dynamite and
even the embarrassment of New Year's Eve
possibly killing Elizabeth burning down
the restaurant by July 44 agents were
working on the case okay
Johnny and Jimmy and Big John were
followed all day all summer
still the FBI could not find a single
piece of evidence they hoped to find
that big John was planning something
else of course at the beginning of
August Big John went to a Fresno
electrical supply store and bought 20
switches right away right away that's it
he's got 20 switches nope he told Jimmy
this time Harvey would pay five million
dollars okay on August um we got dimmers
1981 the FBI head agent went to Johnny's
door and asked him again to explain his
whereabouts and what he'd done on August
24 this and Johnny did again but this
time the agent poked holes in his story
and John had trouble answering anytime
he'd ask question right he was stumbling
so you can poke new holes in his story
sounds right it turns out his story
wasn't making sense the next day that
agent went in front of the grand jury
and told them everything Johnny had said
and the evidence that proved he was
lying Johnny was indicted for perjury
and arrested okay Jimmy came down
voluntarily to talk they both stuck to
their stories for a while about that you
know we come here for profession almost
done we're like
yeah what are you where are you going
we can vamp from it yeah we'll wait cool
sounds better out there go down like two
minutes so they're doing some sprinkling
stuff at the studio or does this get cut
out of the podcast
mm what you're worried about what well
you didn't say nobody living here no
it's fine
so Johnny and Jimmy stick to their
stories for a while but finally Johnny
cracks and then Jimmy and they started
talking they wouldn't stop talking okay
Big John and John were arrested he
blamed Johnny for shooting off his mouth
okay the boys were kept in protective
custody in Fresno how old are they
they're 19 okay
well Johnny turns 21 while they're okay
they're still young yeah they're in the
Fresno Hilton and they're allowed to
order whatever they wanted oh my god the
fact that that's something you're
telling me Johnny had a blast I wonder
if I have that picture I had a picture
of them hanging out with the FBI agent
so they just are like they're there oh
right there okay so they're hanging out
with the FBI the FBI agents on his
birthday give him a card signed with the
nicknames he had given them oh so
they're I mean the dad's they never had
I mean honestly could it look like he's
wearing a nightie
more yes look at the trials the boys
were great witnesses they had great
memories Big John after a while decided
to act as his own lawyer and fired his
lawyers he told the prosecutors he built
the bomb but that he'd been forced by
the mob to do it okay as a lawyer and if
he blew up Harvey's his debts would go
away but if he didn't they'd [ __ ] him
when he cross-examined his sons he
suggested Jimmy put him up to bombing
Harvey's to get college money
he offered he also suggested the leader
of the Douglas County Fire Department
bomb squad had blown up Harvey's so he's
kind of Smasher
on March 7th 1985 Janos Burgess was
found guilty on eight counts he got life
in prison Johnny and Jimmy pleaded
guilty and got immunity they did not
serve a day come on you guys your
sentence to no gays bill and Terry got
seven years each okay John got seven
years but it was later overturned on
appeal okay the boys never saw Big John
again Jimmy wrote a letter apologizing
quote you are the smartest and most
remarkable person in the world I respect
you more than anything and I will try to
be worthy of you I often lie awake at
night thinking of what I have done to
you I cry often at the thought of what I
did the other way but that's fine yeah I
definitely think maybe to some extent
there's a little bit of protectionism
and that that you're just like just in
case you choose through the bars like I
just want to know I feel bad because the
last thing you want to hear is like year
big John's out oh god I should have said
the letter
Big John died of liver cancer in 1996
bill and Terry were released from prison
in 1986 bill died in 1994 and Terry in
2005 Jimmy started a welding and
fabrication business he had three kids
is that where you just weld and say you
do other things yeah yeah we weld and we
make canoes and we're just welders he
coached Little League he raced cars in
his spare time he had a nice business a
nice life going well Johnny had a worse
time he had the same name as Big John so
people didn't want the son of a bomber
working on their roofs John yeah I mean
yeah he moved to bakers
and started doing a lot of cocaine
that's that was law then right yeah yeah
his fiancee died in a car accident he
moved around he was drunk and he got in
fights all the time he would get locked
up for a few months at a time and one
point in prison he wrote a book about
the bombing and he embellished it and he
published it himself but as a novel a
year later he had not sold a single copy
boy that's tough a plexiglass your
family won't even pick one up so a
plexiglass model of the bomb now exists
oh wow and it is still used to train the
FBI's explosive technicians in Quantico
oh so it was so complex that they used
to train people still yeah it's still
considered one of the most complex bombs
that remain and what you didn't have was
the plexiglass right yeah they continued
oh wow crazy right yeah yeah you weed
him out real quick would you get it wet
yeah probably get out go ahead oh good
god Jimmy wow that's crazy that is crazy
oh so now we're just gonna take a which
is for sale to go to red bubble fostex
red bubble page and you will find our
art and that's the news mother loves
Jose that's not life-size life-size he's
like a it's like a cow it's like a smoke
is that way he's in the water he's
comfortable and well that's cream so
it's not water that's cream
yeah I'll notice that I wouldn't point
out that the Jaguars not [ __ ] with
him so that tells you something all
right so uh thank you for joining us
thank you for coming mother I was a long
what did you think okay thank you you're
welcome
yeah do you want to say thank you to
Dave thank you Dave the English you can
just make say thank you for anything you
know it works yeah thank me mother oh
thank you you're welcome
[Laughter]
all right
we signed bombs that the FBI still uses
people to learn how to disarm bombs okay
okay I was a banger